[Music]
do you think that all reasoning
uh even scientific reasoning and or
moral reasoning as you
as you would argue necessarily relies
on unprovable assumptions so i think
there are certain things
certain limited things we know with
something close to certainty one's own
conscious experience if i'm in pain
it's just totally evident that that
feeling of pain is real
or maybe certain elementary truths of
mathematics or logic
but i think any step beyond that yes
involves adopting
certain unprovable assumptions now you
may say
well look the assumptions science rests
on have been proven they've been proven
they work but
i mean i agree with that but
it's it sort of involves a circular
argument if we're asking
is it okay to trust our senses because
you can only know that science works
if you already trust your experience and
your memory
um i don't think there's any way of
breaking out of that circle
all anyone has access to is the
cartesian solipsism of my experience
right now
and to get beyond that you need to have
an act of trust
and also i mean science is also
dependent on
certain unprovable assumptions such as
that the future will resemble the past
any inductive inference is dependent on
that
the great scottish philosopher hume
pointed to the
the impossibility of giving any
non-circular justification of induction
also that simpler theories are more
likely to be true than complex theories
any for any empirical data there are
always an infinite number of theories
compatible
with that data scientists choose between
them on the basis of simplicity elegance
parsimony but why on earth should a
simpler theory be more likely to be true
that is this something we can test for
so yes i think of course once once you
have those starting points
what you do with it can be rational or
irrational
but those basic starting points of
knowledge cannot themselves
be rationally or empirically
demonstrated
carlo what would you think to that
discussion descartes is alive and well
we can't
we can't we can't verify much beyond
what we immediately experience and we
simply have to have faith
in our incomplete knowledge um
once again i i think it's ill formulated
it's badly ill-formulated
uh i think let me put it this way
certainty
it's badly over-appreciated
uh we don't need certainty i think that
a lot of
mistakes that humankind does uh
including in philosophy
uh the reason all philosophers
uh wonderful ideas haven't ended up
convincing everybody that they were
right
it's because uh at a large extent there
was a
search for certainty why do we need
certainty
what what what do we do good with
certainty i am a human being
i'm perfectly happy with the reliability
if i ask
how do i get to to to to downtown to
piccadilly circus
i don't want an answer which is certain
100 i want a reliable answer i mean
how do i know that the guy isn't
cheating me are the two not related in
some way
this is not about the certain final
picture of the world
science is the best we can say about the
world to navigate it
uh politics is not about i'm absolutely
sure that
sure that my politics it's a true i'm
i'm the one it's just what i
am i defend my political ideas because
that's and and maybe i can change my
mind
so if we give up from certainty this um
anguish
about oh there are unprobable
assumptions in our knowledge
of course there are that's why we're
trying to develop it
that's why we do science that's why we
discuss in politics that was with a
discussion about moral arguments
right because it's the point is not
about provable
the point about it's about convincing
convincing one another that one thing is
better than the other
let me disagree with philip
and let me test him on that strongly
because i don't
uh share his uh uh philosophy
in one specific point in my world view
in my understanding uh it's not true at
all
that uh we are locked in a cartesian
solipsism
and there is something and only
something which is evident to us
which is our own consciousness our own
subjective perspective or anything like
that in fact my world views the opposite
is that this uh uh uh
cartesian solipsism it's a late uh
construction of a certain culture uh
and a much more immediate world view
it's the opposite uh there are things
the brothers there are things in fact
there are
the the other human beings and oh by the
way why don't human beings happen to be
me so it's a later construction
so even that i would disagree with them
with him
not because i think he's wrong uh
necessarily that's
one possible way of starting your world
thinking
but there are
of self just consider that nonsense
surely surely sorry to cut in but surely
this is where
i have to say what's so refreshing about
this whole discussion
is that it comes with such humility
and curiosity as well as such advocacy
and expertise and sometimes it is like
humility and that curiosity
or doubt or whatever you want to that we
are that we are missing
and when i listen to to to philip
talk about the the contradiction of of
some of his philosopher colleagues
you know that that um you know that um
something that i touch is real but
something that i feel is not and
he talked about how he felt when he
witnessed
george floyd's murder which of course is
something that because of this amazing
technology we can
we can now watch in our millions all
over the world in
in intimate ways that wouldn't be the
case some years ago
of course he was feeling that and he was
experiencing that but
so were millions and millions of
other people who who describe
similar feelings to the one that the
to the feeling that philip had now of
course that's predicated on the idea
that all of those people are real and
not just figments of
philip's imagination brought to him via
zoom
of course of course of course of course
i must trust that i'm really looking at
carlow right now
and not the true and not the truman show
or or something that was
you know that's been beamed to me from
outer space but but
we get political i think when
we and we can't run away from the plot
we cannot use either science or religion
to run away from the politics
of how we navigate i think was
a word that that carlo used and possibly
philip as well how
we navigate this world together using
such
limited language and unlimited curiosity
how we deal with that doubt and one of
the things i'm worried about
in politics and as a human rights
advocate is that sometimes the people
without
doubt people the people with absolute
certainty
whether in their science or whether in
their in their
faith or their politics they are so
powerful
and shrill and intimidating
to to millions and millions of people
with a element of of
of doubt and that that they win
in some very um illiberal uh
intemperate way and it's a very good way
to grab power
in this world to claim absolute
certainty is is a great way to be a
great dictator in this world still
still now in the 21st century look at
donald trump i have another i have
another question
related to the reaction to watching the
george floyd
video because you're you tend to assume
that
that the vast majority of people or
everyone had the same
reaction but it but people approach
thing
even extreme things like that from a
very different perspective and you
these assumptions are not uh
unquestionable
well of course you are right and what
happened was that millions of people
went one way and millions of people went
the other way
and it turned out to be an incredibly
polar and remains
an incredibly polarizing event but the
one
the one um thing we we sort of know is
that
it didn't there's not that many people
who perhaps felt nothing i think
i think if somebody felt absolute and
there must be some who felt absolutely
nothing
undoubtedly but i think that some kind
of reaction
whatever people say what even whatever
people tell the focus group
or or say on twitter i suspect that some
kind
of reaction if you measured people's
impulses in some scientific ways some
kind of reaction to that
probably registered to most sentient
human beings and as you say
isabel the polarizing thing
is that for some people that is a very
very painful
in injustice to continue watching this
video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas